la semaine dernière le journaliste
patrick poivre d'arvor historiquement à
la tête du journal de 20 heures de tf1 a
été publiquement accusé de viol par
l'écrivaine florence porcel à patrick
poivre d'arvor l'ancien présentateur
vedette aurait visé par une enquête pour
viol alors que l'afer a fait la une de
l'actualité et que les médias relayent
les nombreux témoignages qui évoque le
rapport aux femmes particulièrement
obsessionnel journalistes ppda a décidé
de sortir du silence et de répondre à
ces accusations
dans un message posté sur facebook de
toute ma vie je n'ai jamais obliger
quiconque à une relation sentimentale ni
bien évidemment à une relation sexuelle
il précise que pour lui ces attaques
sont révoltantes et insupportable le
journaliste est prêt aujourd'hui à
répondre sur les faits et se dit armé
pour prouver son innocence
les écrits de madame florence porcel que
j'ai conservé pour la plupart
postérieure à ces accusations le
prouveront amplement alors la réponse de
ppda vous at elle convaincu
la réponse de pda et sachez qu'un bon
couteau qui nous disait ce que m e
division va revenir wigan et se reposer
un petit peu on va le rafraîchir et
toujours dix minutes pour parler du
sujet de the voice ne vous inquiétez pas
ils reversaient à l'effet des sorties de
scène comme ça il reviendra dans un
instant ppda sur du cid ans accusé de
viol la réponse de ppda vous at elle
convaincu
on a vu des extraits de cette réponse
guillaume genton oui moi ça m'a
convaincu c'est très bien dans ce genre
d'affaires de réagir immédiatement ne
serait ce qu'en termes de communication
et moi je me suis intéressé au
traitement médiatique de cette affaire
et je me suis rendu compte que tf1 qui
est la chaîne historique un de ppda est
la chaîne qui a passé le moins de temps
regardez je vous ai fait un petit
tableau sur le traitement de la sphère
dans ses jt sur un jt moyens vous avez
les chaînes principales qui traite la
sphère ppda pendant une douzaine d'avis
dans le tableau 1 il arrive qu'il va
arriver
alors allez-y pas commenter le guen cinq
minutes sur france 2 la ramasse 12
minutes sur bfm et seulement 19 secondes
sur tf1 ils n'ont même pas si 19
secondes la plaignante ils n'ont pas
cité de nom a dénoncé la chaîne la seule
chaîne à ne pas l'avoir cité c'est
incroyable ça va oui gilbert déhancher
en total désaccord et guillaume a
prononcé le mot c'est de la
communication
c'est pour ça vous êtes obligés de
réagir oui je vous donne mon avis c'est
pour ça que la communication de patrick
poivre d'arvor encore une fois présumé
innocent me choque beaucoup parce que
c'est un communiqué qui a été rédigée au
mot près avec un avocat
c'est un communiqué qui parle aux
enquêteurs il a accepté d'être entendu
il sera entendu
c'est un communiqué qui parle à
l'opinion c'est pas un communiqué
sincère c'est pas un communiqué de lui
et c'est une réponse inadaptée à ce que
les gens attendent l
j'en voulais de la sincérité ils ont de
la communication pour moi c'est un coup
d'épée dans l'eau de la part de patrick
poivre d'arvor
oui il a encore le droit de choisir
comment ils défauts mais je vous donne
mon opinion sur on juge la communication
pour moi elle est mauvaise d'accord
garder un droit de choisir sa ligne de
défense il va pas dire qu'il est
coupable alors qu'il n'est pas coupable
si jamais il n'est pas coupable et je
trouve que en plus cette affaire que
comme je disais elle pose une vraie
question sur qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui alors qu'on parle de viol
c'est extrêmement grave évidemment mais
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être un art c'est
l'heure je me rappelle que harceleur
nouvelle vendredi valérie a parlé d'une
anecdote avec ppda qui l'avait invité à
dîner de manière elle en parlait de
manière respectueuse pour d'autres
femmes ça va être perçu comme du
harcèlement
donc c'est vrai que cette limite parfois
elle est très mince elle est difficile à
cerner alors vous l'avez dit tf1 a à
peine évoqué la faire ses révélations
beaucoup agacé sur les réseaux sociaux
sur toute la direction de tf1 n'aurait
jamais été au courant
voilà il ya david perrotin d'un
excellent journaliste de médiapart je
vous dis voilà il a fait comme une étude
sur et un reportage sur le refuge n'est
qu'une stagiaire arriver on lui disait
t'es pas ce fait c'est fait gaffe ne
m'ont jamais seul dans l'ascenseur avec
ppda le journaliste est accusé de
nombreuses agressions sexuelles de
harcèlement la direction de tf1 dit elle
n'avoir jamais été alertés une
révélation qui a énervé notre ami
clément garonne la direction de tf1 dit
nous savons de n'avoir jamais été
alertée alors que c'est un secret de
polichinelle depuis des années qu'elle
un dîner et à tf1 les témoignages à
l'encontre de ppda commencent à
s'accumuler et si tf1 affirme ne jamais
avoir été alertée 20 minutes apporte une
autre version
selon la direction des ressources
humaines étaient bien au courant des
agissements problématique de la part de
patrick poivre d'arvor c'est le 20
minutes qui le dit voilà amy a jamais eu
une plainte
bien sûr non mais c'est sûr ben voilà
temps mais c'est important de le dire il
avalera les rumeurs de couloir en disant
attention on sait que ça bien sûr et il
n'a pas besoin de courir mais qui que ce
soit je veux vous dire qu'il connaît
voilà toutes les femmes les corées après
la plupart des femmes couraient après
c'est un dragueur et peut-être lourdaud
parfois peut-être en tout cas il a
toujours été je crois d'une élégance
remarquable
maintenant tout ça c'est très étonnant
et quand on dit ici défendu avec ses
avocats non il n'a pas besoin d'avocat
il a bien regrette odeurs non mais moi
j'ai trouvé que le texte je vous dirais
tj je me sens un peu dur je trouve que
c'est mais c'est que c'était lui qui
avait cramé complètement moi je lui
donnons aux bouquins et c'est un auteur
c'est s'écrire le mec n'a pas besoin
d'avocat pour écrire ses textes et il a
dit quelque chose de très important
parce que toute la défense va être basé
là dessus si tu savais c'est toujours
parole contre parole il a dit surtout il
n'y a jamais eu aucune forme
d'entreprise ni a fortiori de
contraintes
c'est ça qui est important pour cette
jeune femme voilà qui l'accusent elle a
connu il ya des années à la revue la
cherche à le revoir bernard michel a vu
l la revue mais ces sportifs victimes ce
sont des faits ça on s'en fiche que pour
toi c'est important mais une personne
qui a été victime qu'elle soit revenu
qu'elles soient parties savent rien hier
résumé victimes non m'attend je te dis
je te parle de fait je te parle pas
arrivé si tu sais latics important c'est
pas ce qui est arrivé moi j'étais pas
dans l'ordre dans l'ensemble wire 10
allemands qui sont des filles sont vus
et revus et l'a sollicité et lui
maintenant il va fournir des sms qu'elle
en est d'ailleurs entre toi et là qui
vont d'après lui totalement le disculper
s'il y avait un doute il va le lever
d'accord daniel moi je gilles excuse moi
mais même si c'est un avocat qui est
derrière ce communiqué donc ça a été
mais les deux pages dans le dans le
parisien le lendemain de la plainte
parce que la plaignante falla personnes
qui portent plainte elle a tout à fait
le droit et on est tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il faut le droit à la parole
mais les deux pages dans le parisien je
suis désolé en une seconde et ça a tué
ppda bien sûr cela on raconte des choses
horribles sur lui jg deux anecdotes en
en tête je ne pourrais pas la plus
revoir ppda je me connais depuis vingt
ans et quelqu'un j'ai toujours toujours
faut l'avoir avec moi évidemment mais
même avec les autres outils quelqu'un
qui est très séducteur mais je pense
très respectueux ça l'a tué en vraiment
on peut tuer quelqu'un à l'image a bien
sûr de quelques joueurs en une matinée
deux pages dans le parisien ça restera
tout le temps et avec les les anecdotes
pourri qu'on a raconté je suis désolé
c'est voilà ça c'est grave la plainte
elle a tout à fait le droit je n'ai pas
à juger cette affaire
mais ça c'est grave voilà il semblerait
se défendre moi je respecte totalement
la parole des victimes
évidemment d enfin de celles qui se
disent victimes de violence est
primordial mais je trouve que de la
parole de la défense aussi est
primordial haussier à l'heure où les
réseaux sociaux et l'ensemble des médias
font qui sait ça devient immédiatement
une curie il fait qu on acte qu'on
aurait une cure et c'est dans le poulain
dont voilà et que la culpabilité précède
de plusieurs années souvent le procès
moi je connais un peu p table pour
l'avoir vu on peut dire qu'il est
lourdingue vous dire qu'il était
peut-être harcelant va si vite a insisté
qu on veut mais le viol c'est qu'un tout
autre chose
l'escroc en fin de
j'aime quand même qu'à chaque fois ce
genre de d'accusation arrivons à un
moment de promotion commerciale pour la
sortie d'un livre c'est quand même comme
et vinci qu'on nous dise que tout le
monde prend comme les matches victoire
ce qui me gêne c'est ça c'est à dire que
de mettre ça il ya effectivement la
présomption d'innocence bien sûr et plus
personne mais c'est une réponse
juridique je suis totalement d'accord
avec ce que dit gilles et de l'autre
côté les gens commencent à dire que
c'est de la publicité que ce serait du
buzz par rapport à part par rapport à
quelqu'un qui sortira un livre ça je
trouve ça vraiment déplacé est-ce qu'ils
ont des lois aussi il faut effectivement
respectées aussi sa parole à tout le
monde de dire s'il ya des gens de
l'autre côté maintenant je rejoins
gilles sur l'aspect juridique je trouve
que la réponse est extrêmement juridique
et ce qui m'a gêné quand même c'est
cette phrase de dire l'utilisation faite
de sa personne pour assurer la promotion
d'un roman je trouve que c'est malvenu
dans ce genre de situation d'edf sa
voilà ça avec ce qu'il a pris depuis
quelques temps alors castaldi non moi je
honnêtement je suis d'accord avec les
banques bear un qui connaît rien ou
mesdames hangar un gamin c'est vrai que
ces journalistes tout le monde tout le
monde savait que le [ __ ] avait tendance à
être un gros dragueur parfois insistant
mais encore une fois on peut pas juger
l'homme avant qu'il y ait un procès est
encore une fois
effectivement les deux passent devant le
parisien le progrès à sa carrière avait
fracassé aucun d'entre nous à cette
table on est à l'abri moi demain matin
si quelqu'un porte plainte contre moi ce
sera ma parole contre contre la sienne
et vous pareil je pense que moi je vais
le faire pour vous mais c'est très grave
et quand vous perdez et je sais d'accord
voilà mécénat mais c'est un vrai
problème
et encore il faut la célébrité n'est pas
un paravent n'est n'est pas un bouclier
mais franchement faut pas que ça avait
une multitudes que tous les deux jours
on soit accusé le fils bâtard vous étiez
miss france justement ppda il était
encore au jt ou pas
non tout débuts de gilles bouleau
d'accord très bien voilà mais bernard ce
que tu as dit tout à l'heure c'est que
pour l'instant il n'y a jamais eu de
plainte et dans le temps n'y a jamais eu
de plainte parce que dans le temps ça ne
se faisait pas non plus voilà enfin
auteur faut pas dire qu a pas eu de
plainte parce qu'à pas être plainte ya
pas être plains pas ça se faisait pas et
aujourd'hui à la libération donc faut
pas qu'ils aiment sur libération mais il
faut quand même écouter ce qui se dit et
il se dit des choses dans les couloirs
mais les gens ne disent pas forcément
les choses concernant moi ce qui me fait
peur c'est qu'on est en train de faire
on est en train d'entrer ils y allaient
les carrières de une personne qui est
détruite chaque semaine et une personne
du du showbiz entre guillemets qui est
en train de tomber chaque semaine
c'était richard berry la semaine
dernière ppda là donc soit on est dans
un milieu où il ya que des paires mer et
des détraqués soit ya de l'abus
mais ça fait peur quand même chaque
semaine ya un mec qui tombe non mais ça
fait peur la bonne nouvelle c'est que
dans le communiqué il dit rétablir son
honneur et la vérité des faits et on la
connaîtra la vérité des faits parce que
tout le monde sera entendu
la plaignante oui mais ça il mais ça
c'est fini pour lui après mais le
malaise c'est fini ça va on va on le
saura dans dans six mois dans un an
c'est terminé le mal est fait les faits
supposés vous dire moi je parlais tout à
l'heure du refuge de refuge il avait
fait une fausse déclaration oui sur moi
tout le monde en avait parlé
tout le monde avait ni cyril hanouna
derrière david perrotin voilà qui a fait
une enquête magnifique a dit voilà que
c'était un faux il avait fait un faux
témoignage
aujourd'hui vous savez que le président
du refuge de l'époque a été sorti voilà
et ça personne ne l'a repris ça voilà
très peu de gens le rugby c'est à dire
que voilà donc à un moment quand le mal
est fait le mal est fait la une des
médias qui office pression démenti cette
année tandis que moi ça fait un scandale
épouvantable
oui il ya eu un bateau csa ya eu trois
minassian parce qu'ils voient les
conséquences un peu tard latics il a
peint président de deux chefs jacques
survient il élit le fout dehors en 2008
g
non mais c'est un drame oui pour un truc
et fute fute fute de a à z donc moi je
suis au aujourd'hui la parole à les
libérer
et c'est très bien parce
qu'effectivement il y en a et il y en a
qui ont abusé et bien sûr est vraiment
vraiment abusés et d'ailleurs ces gens
là généralement ils sont reconnaissables
on les connaît c'est ça le plus grave
d'ailleurs j'en ai un peu tout ça c'est
pour ça parce que personne n'a bougé en
temps et en heure ça c'est la vérité
mais maintenant que j'ai des plaintes
déposées moi j'en sais rien si bébé né à
la fait pour l'instant je n'en sais rien
ce que je vois c'est que ce ce monsieur
réputation de gros dragueur un peu
insistant un peu lourdaud et
qu'aujourd'hui il est traîné au tribunal
pour viol est un viol c'est très grave
voile alors on regarde s'il vous plaît
le sondage oui à 59% non à 41% clan